how's it going everybody
it's Warren with a quick update video
here about new footage and a TV spot for
Avengers in game at the Superbowl it's
been highly speculated that Disney and
Marvel would show new footage of
Avengers in game at the Super Bowl this
Sunday February 3rd this follows the
Marvel tradition of showing new footage
of brand-new movies they have coming out
at the Super Bowl they've done this for
the past several years so they've had a
big presence at the Super Bowl and now
it has been confirmed that Disney has
bought an undisclosed amount of TV spots
airing during the Super Bowl this Sunday
and some recent reports from ad age and
trailer track have said that there's
going to be new footage of Avengers in
game shown during the Super Bowl
sometime now this is not going to be the
official trailer 2 for Avengers in game
this will be a 30-second TV spot much
like we saw many of for Avengers
infinity war aired during the Super Bowl
some time again Marvel and Disney have
done this for many years now showing new
footage of their new movies coming out
during the Super Bowl they've done this
for movies such as guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 Captain America Civil War
and of course Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame seems to be following
the same path that Avengers infinity war
did releasing a teaser trailer followed
by a TV spot during the Superbowl and
then the full official trailer after
right now the full official trailer for
Avengers in game is speculated to come
out sometime during March around the
release of Captain Marvel again this
would follow the same release schedule
that they did for Avengers infinity war
so again it has been confirmed that
Disney has bought slots for commercials
during the Superbowl and according to
reports a teaser for Avengers in game
will be shown with a little bit of new
footage so be sure to tune in to the
Super Bowl this Sunday February 3rd and
just a reminder there are only four days
left in my Infinity Gauntlet giveaway I
will be picking a new winner on February
1st if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]